ابدا مدير وكاله المخابرات المركزيه
الامريكيه ويليام بيرز خشيته من ان
الاوضاع الراهنه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه قد
تقود الى اندلاع انتفاضه ثالثه وقال بيرز
ان محادثاته الاخيره مع القاده
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين تركته اكثر
قلقا بشان احتمالات تفاقم العنف بين
الجانبين
تصريحاته هذه تاتي بعد جوله لبليكن في
المنطقه سعيا للتهدئه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كان ذاك خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما
المعطيات التي دفعت واشنطن لترجيح اندلاع
انتفاضه ثالثه والتحذير من تصاعد اكثر
للعنف وما دلاله افصاح المخابرات
الامريكيه عن هذه القراءه بعيده زياره
بلينكن الى تل ابيب ورام الله في محاوله
لتهدئه الوضع
وما هي حقيقه ما طلبه بلينكن من عباس
بخصوص خطه لضبط الاوضاع في جنين ونابلس
وما الذي ردد به السلطه الفلسطينيه وماذا
سيكون دورها في حال دلعت انتفاضه اخرى
كيف ستكون الانتفاضه المحتمله من ناحيه
ادواتها وقد دخل السلاح الناري على الخط
في الضفه وكيف ستتفاعل حكومه نتنياهو
اليمينيه والولايات المتحده وعامه المجتمع
الدولي معه
[موسيقى]
هي قراءه امريكيه للاحتمالات المتعلقه
بافوق الاوضاع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
قراءه تكمن اهميتها في كونها تصدر عن مدير
وكاله المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه بعد
زيارته هو وزياره كل من وزير الخارجيه
ومستشار الامن القومي جاك سليفان الى
المنطقه نتابع اولا ما قاله ويليام
في محادثات مع القاده الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين خرجت بانطباع جعلني اشعر
بقلق بالغ بشان احتمالات مزيد من العنف
بين الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين وقد كنت
دبلوماسيا كبيرا خلال الانتفاضه الثانيه
واشعر انا وزملائي في مجتمع الاستخبارات
بان كثيرا مما نراه اليوم يشبه للغايه ما
رايناه حينها وجزء من مسؤوليه وكاله
الاستخبارات المركزيه هو العمل بشكل وثيق
قدر الامكان مع كل من اجهزه الامن
الفلسطينيه واجهزه الامن الاسرائيليه
للحيلوله دون تفجر ذلك النوع من العنف
المساعي الامريكيه في المنطقه تندرج تحت
عنوان عريض هو البحث عن التهدئه استباقا
للاسوا لكن صوره بقيه غامضه بشان ما اذا
كان بلينكن قد مارس ضغوطا على الرئيس
الفلسطيني محمود عباس للقبول بخطه امريكيه
تهدف لايقاف العنف موقع اكسيوس نقل عن
مسؤولين امريكيين واسرائيليين ان الخطه
التي راقت تل ابيب تدعو الى تشكيل قوه
فلسطينيه خاصه مهمتها مواجهه ما يعتبره
الامريكيون مسلحين في مدينتي جنين ونابلس
في المقابل مفاه مستشار وزير الخارجيه
الفلسطينيه احمد الديك ان يكون بلينكن قد
عرض اي خطه امنيه على الرئاسه الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
في هذا الموضوع معنا من نيوجيرسي
المبعوث الخاص السابق للرئيس بيل كلينتون
لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط ومن الخليل معنا عادل
شديد الباحث المختص بشان الاسرائيلي لو
بدانا معك سيد ريتشارد جودستين
وانطلاقا مما قاله ويليام بيرز يطرح
السؤال ما هي العوامل المتشابهه والتي
جعلته يعتقد بانه يمكن ان تكون هناك
انتفاضه ثالثه ما هي العوامل المتشابهه
اليوم مع ما سبق الانتفاضه الثانيه
لقد قال ان هذا التشابه غير سعيد اطلاقا
بالظروف التي سبقت الانتفاضه الثانيه وكان
يشير بذلك الى ما نشهده جميعا
اسرائيل بالتاكيد لديها لدى العليا وهناك
شعور كبير بالاحباط لدى الفلسطينيين الذين
يريدون الاستقلاليتهم ولا يودوا ان لا
يسجدون الطريق مفتوحا امامهم ولكن طبعا ان
اسرائيل طبقت علاقاتها مع دول الخليج
وبالتالي هذا يجعل الفلسطينيين يشعرون
باحباط وعزله اكبر ولو لكن لو نظرنا الى
ما حصل منذ انتفاضتين الاولى والثانيه نجد
ان الظروف الضفه الغربيه لم تتحسن بشكل
كبير ولكن اسرائيل اصبحت اكثر قوه عسكريا
واقتصاديا واصبحت
مصدر حسد من كل عالم التكنولوجيا وبالتالي
ليس من واضح ان كانت الانتفاضه جديده
ستساعد الفلسطيني على تحقيق اهدافهم ظن
الكثير منهم سيحاولون ان يفكروا بذلك
ويحققوهم صيد عادل شديد الواقع الفلسطيني
اليوم هل يشبه الواقع الفلسطيني الذي سبق
الانتفاضه الثانيه في الماضي
ويقول ويليام بنز انه بعد محادثته مع
الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين اصبح اكثر قلقا من تصعيد
اوسع
تحياتي لك استاذ حسن ولضيفك
وللمشاهدين
اعتقد انه
اللقاءات الامريكيه بالمنطقه ما بين
القياده الفلسطينيه
والحكومه الاسرائيليه وممثلي اسرائيل كشفت
ان الفجوه الحاليه بالمواقف
كبيره وبعيده جدا وامكانيه الحفاظ على
الوضع القائم واستمرار ابر التخدير
بالحاله الفلسطينيه تحديدا واستمرار
التنسيق الامني انه المساله اصبحت مستحيله
في ظل
حكومه اسرائيليه لها برنامج ومعنيه
ومستمره بذهاب وترجمه وتنفيذ هذا المشروع
من شانه ان يؤدي الى اشعال المنطقه وخاصه
في ملفات القدس والمسجد الاقصى وموضوع
الاستيطان وموضوع الاسرى ثم انه
واضح الان للامريكان انه الاسرائيليين لم
يعودوا معنيين فقط ببقاء الدوري الامني
والاقتصادي للسلطه وانما
عزلها بشكل تام عن اي دور السياسي سواء
فيما يتعلق بالتوجه للمؤسسات الدوليه
للامم المتحده لمجلس الامن حتى اصبح
النقاش الاسرائيلي ينظر الى هاي المحاولات
الفلسطينيه
بنوع من الارهاب ويسمى بالارهاب
الدبلوماسي او الارهاب السياسي ويراد
ابقاء السلطه ليس فقط
بسياق امنيه انما بالسياق الامني الذي
تحدده اجهزه الامن الاسرائيليه واللي بات
واضح للقياده الفلسطينيه انه هذا الواقع
بقائه سيؤدي الى تاكل ما تبقى من شرعيه
ومن مكاني ومن حضور فالسلطه بالشارع
الفلسطيني وبالراي العام الفلسطيني الذي
سياتي بنتائج عكسيه تماما طيب هذا يعني
يدفع الى السؤال من جديد ضيفنا الامريكي
ريتشارد جوتشتاين على من تقع مسؤوليه
الانتفاضه الثالثه لو حصلت بالفعل من وجهه
نظر اسرائيليه على اسرائيل ام على الجانب
الفلسطيني الذي يبدو انه في وارد رد فعل
انا اعترف بانه حتى الحديث عن تفاظ
الثالثه
اكثر معقولا واكثر امكانيه ولكن افضل ان
نتوقع امكانيه تجنب ذلك هنا من هو المذنب
فكل جانب يوجه اصابعه نحو الاخر
الاسرائيليون
التي حصلت في جنين اذ يقولون انهم توجهوا
الى جنين للبحث عن المسؤولين
ليس ليس سؤالي من من من الطرفين يحمل
الاخر المسؤوليه سالتك اذا اندلعت
الانتفاضه من وجهه نظر امريكيه من يتحمل
المسؤوليه اكثر اسرائيل ام الفلسطينيون من
وجهه نظر امريكيه
اعتقد ان الجواب يعتمد على الظروف افهموا
ان هناك عدم راحه
يشعر بها اداره بايدن حول
اليمين المطرف الموجود في حكومه نتنياهو
وطريقه تعاملهم اعتقد هذا هو جزء كبير من
النقاشات بين الوزير بلينكن هو السيد
نتنياهو مؤخرا
هو ذلك للتاكد من الامور لا تخرج عن
السيطره قبل ان يفوت الاوان ولكن مره اخرى
اقول اننا لا نعلم احد منا يستطيع ان يعرف
المستقبل اللي يعرف كيف يمكن ان تكون
الانتفاضه وكيف تبدا لا اعتقد ان بدي
تشاهدنا لحد الان بدايه انتفاضه وهل ستكون
زياده في عسكره العسكره والتوجه العسكري
لدى فلسطين بالحصول على المزيد ويزيد من
الاسلحه في الظفر الغربيه هل سيكون هجوم
مداهمه تقوم باسرائيل لا نعم نامل ان ما
نستطيع ان نامل انها لن تتحقق كل احصل ذلك
طيب بالاشاره هنا الى ان الاوضاع الحاليه
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه تثير قلقا اقليميا
ودوليا لا يقتصر على الولايات المتحده فقط
فها هو الرئيس الفرنسي من هو الماكرون
يؤكد خلال استقباله نتنياهو على ضروره
تجنب اي اجراء من شانه تاجيج دوامه العنف
الرئاسه الفرنسيه اضافت في بيان ان ماكرون
ابدى معارضته الشديده لاستمرار الاستيطان
الذي يقوض احتمالات قيام دوله فلسطينيه في
المستقبل وفق البيان رحب ماكرون بتطبيع
العلاقات بين اسرائيل ودول عده في المنطقه
لكنه قال ان الديناميكيه هذه ستبقى غير
مكتمله ما دامت غير مصحوبه باستئناف عمليه
سياسيه نحو حل للصراع الاسرائيلي
الفلسطيني
نعود الى ضيفنا عادل شديد سيد عادل يعني
هذا القلق الذي عبر عنه ويليام ترافق مع
ما اعلن عن انه حمل خطه امنيه لسلطه
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
بتدريب مجموعات لمواجهه من اعتبرهم مسلحين
فلسطينيين في الضفه هل يبدو الامر وكانه
نوع من التهديد او مقايضه اما ان
يحصل او تنفذ هذه الخطه واما ان تكون هناك
اجراءات اسرائيليه اكبر وتصعيد اكبر ويؤدي
الى انتفاضه ثالثه تقوض السلطه
يعني واضح ان المقاربه الامريكيه تبدا
وتنتهي بالموضوع الامني والاستقرار وما له
من علاقه بالاستقرار الاقليمي والدولي
ولكن كما تحدثنا انه واضح الان انه هاي
المقاربه وصلت الى نهايه لم يعد بالامكان
الاستمرار بالحاله الحاليه انه السلطه جزء
من حاله استقرار ودورها امني فقط وبالتالي
وصلت القياده الفلسطينيه الى هاي الخلاصه
وهذا تم التعبير عنه بعدم ادانه العمليات
التي حدثت بالقدس وخاصه انه الامريكان
بهذه المقاربه
يحاولون طرح المشكله وكانها امنيه وكانها
بالعمليات الفدائيه الفلسطينيه في جنين في
نابلس في القدس وليس انها نتاج طبيعي
للاحتلال واجرام واستطعانه وتدنيسه
للمقدسات الاسلاميه وهذا موقف الامريكان
واضح واليوم ما يعمق الاحساس الامريكي
بانه الامور ذاهبه بالاتجاه
التصعيدي والانفجار ليس فقط قراءه دقيقه
وموضوعيه وخاصه انهم سمعوا من الطرفين
ولاطقم الامنيه موجوده وتتابع كل ما يحدث
انما انه قناعه امريكيه انه لم تعد
الاداره الامريكيه تملك الكثير من الاوراق
للضغط وخاصه على الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الحاليه او حتى على القياده الفلسطينيه
باستثناء بضع ملايين الدولارات لوكاله
الغوث بمعنى انه الرهان على انه الامن
مقابل الاقتصاد او الامن مقابل بقاء
السلطه او مقابل امتيازات لم تعد هاي
المساله مقنعه وقادره يعني هذا انه كما
تحدثنا انه نعم
التنسيق الامني كما تريد الاداره
الامريكيه وحكومه اسرائيل بمعزل عن اي بعد
او اي مضمون سياسي هو سيفجر الامور كما
الاجراءات الاسرائيليه الحاليه انت انت
ذكرت نقطه هي مضمون سؤالي للسيد جوتشتاين
من نيوجيرسي
والمتعلقه بقدره الولايات المتحده على
الضغط هنا
[موسيقى]
يعني
ابدى قلقا من تفجر انتفاضه ثالثه لكنه لم
يقدم برنامج عمل
لاحتواء هذا الموقف او لمنع تفجر هذه
الانتفاضه وكانه بذلك يعني
يعترف بالعجز عن وضع حد لهذا التصعيد
الاسرائيلي بالدرجه الاولى ما رايك
نحن لا نعرف ما الذي قيل بل خلف الابواب
الموصده مع السيد باز خلف الابواب المنتدى
مع السيد الوزير عندما التقياه بالسيد
نتنياهو ولكن ما نعرفه
هو ان اطلاق النار على سبعه فلسطين عند
معبد في القدس لم يسرع
عمل عسكري قوي سريع انا اقول ذلك استغربت
لذلك وهذا ايضا مؤشر جيد لان لان هذا لم
يخرج عن السيطره بشكل كبير
كما كان يمكن اي منه يتوقعه قبل السابقه
ان نقول بالتاكيد بان لم تكن هناك خطه
اقترحت او لم تكن هناك اي جزره وعصى وضعت
امامه امامهما
الاسرائيليين مكتوب الامريكا لكن ما نعرف
ما حصل استطيع القول لان الامور مشجعه لحد
الان لانه لم تزداد سوءا ولكن بالتاكيد
هناك امل ان كان واقعيا ام لا هو ان
السلطه الفلسطينيه
يمكن ان تقوم بشيء ما لتحديد العنف الذي
يجري على يد بعض الفلسطينيين
داخل اسرائيل
لماذا تحميل الفلسطينيين دائما المسؤوليه
يعني الولايات المتحده تحملهم الماسونيه
علما ان ما حصل في جنين
قوات الاحتلال لهذه المنطقه وما حصل في
القدس جاء كعمليه رد على قتل اسرائيل تسعه
من الفلسطينيين في جنين فبالتالي لماذا
الجانب الفلسطيني من وجهه نظر امريكيه هو
الذي يجب ان يقدم التنازلات وهو من يتحمل
المسؤوليه
ما قلته قبل دقائق هو هو
ان هو اين هي الخطيه الاساسيه هل لكن
الحكومه الاسرائيليه تقول ان الاقتحام
الجنين كان
لمتابعه
القبضه
وعسكريين في اسرائيل في السنه الماضيه
ولمنع المزيد من مثل هذه عمليات القتل هذه
فيعتقد ان المخابرات الاسرائيليه جيده في
هذا المجال
وهم عملوا تقريبا بشكل اعمى
للتخلص من الفلسطينيين
مقارنه
العمليه التي حصلت في المعبد الديني
اذا كانوا الاكبر عدد من كل مدنيا انا لا
اقول دائما الخطا هو خطا في الصين لا
اعتقد هذا الموقف الامريكي ما افهمه ان
المستوطنات هي مشكله
وهذا ليس المقرون يقول ذلك الحكومه
الامريكيه قال ذلك ولكن فعلا اعتقد انه
دائما شيء مقابل شيء وعليه ان نعود من
الذي هو المسؤول الاول في هذه المنطقه هذا
هو السؤال الصعب الذي يمكن تحديده باصلحته
شديد ما شكل الانتفاضه الثالثه في حال
اندلعت
وطبعا دائما انطلاقا من القلق الامريكي
وما عبر عنه
شكل هذه الانتفاضه وبماذا ستختلف عن
سابقاتها
يعني حتى
القلق الامريكي هذا مرتبط بواقع اليوم
الحالي الفلسطينيه
العمليات النوعيه التي جرت بالشهور
الماضيه واخرها قبل اسبوع بمدينه القدس
المحتله هي
تعكس يعني حاله عميقه جدا من الراي العام
الفلسطيني الذي باتا دائما وحاضنا ومؤيدا
بقوه
لمقاومه الاحتلال وبالمناسبه ردا على حديث
ضيفك من من الولايات المتحدين حتى بدون
عمليه جنين واعدام تسع مواطنين فلسطينيين
بالوضع الطبيعي انه كل القوانين الدوليه
تجيز لا بل تلزم الشعوب المحتله عن تقاوم
قوه الاحتلال بكل الوسائل والاشكال وفي
مقدمتها الكفاح المسلح والوسائل المسلحه
يعني بمعنى انه حتى السنوات
هي مرت فيها حاله مشوهه مرت بها الحاله
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه حين حدثت ولاول مره
بالتاريخ ان يقوم شعب محتل حتى
بمحاوله منع مقاومه قوه الاحتلال كل
الاحوال هذه
المقاربه اعتقد انه وصلت الى الى نهايتها
ليست في عمليه القدس وليست في الموجودين
بجنين وانما بجذر المشكله وهي الاحتلال
الذي هو سبب كل مصائب المنطقه بالحديث هنا
ان يكون نعم بالحديث عن هذه عن التوقعات
طبعا وباختصار شديد اما وقد دخل سلاح الان
واضح ان هناك يعني عمليات في كثير من
الاحيان تكون مسلحه فلسطينيه هل يمكن ان
تكون هذه الانتفاضه الثالثه لو اندلعت
انتفاضه مسلحه وليست كنتفاضه الحجاره
سابقا باختص
يعني بالتاكيد انه منذ عام طرق تحول مهم
جدا بشكل المواجهه ما بين الشعب الفلسطيني
بالضفه تحديدا والاحتلال انه
اصبحت ظاهره استقبال الجنود بكل المدن
بالحجاره تراجعت وحل محلها اطلاق النار
والاكواع المتفجره والعبوات الناسفه وهذا
يشكل مصدر ازعاج كبير للامريكي
والاسرائيلي شكرا احوال اسرائيل اسرائيل
اغرقت المجتمع الفلسطيني بالسلاح اعتقادا
منها انه قد يؤدي الى حرب اهليه اليوم بات
من المؤكد انه اكثريه هذا السلاح سيستخدم
ضد اسرائيل مستقبل عادل شديد من الخليل
شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا
لريتشارد غوتس تايم من نيود جورسين
المبعوث الخاص السابق للرئيس بيل كلينتون
لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط انتهت حلقتنا من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]